[Music]
emergency at the chemical factory no
georgia girls aren't allowed to be
firemen but i'm as brave as any boy it's
my dream it's my destiny
girls can't be firemen give me a break
[Music]
extra extra arsonist again
the firemen
go into the theaters
they don't come out
i need you to run the fire investigation
i'll need a team here's the plan i
joined dad's team egg crate for the
stomach muscles mango for the biceps
and for the mustache
[Music]
oh okay too much
shake what your mama gave you
what your mama gave you
are you one of the volunteers
do i
know
you
let me introduce you the brains of your
operation ricardo
uh ginger driver fastest cabbie in
manhattan
who are you me uh i'm joe i'm fireman
joe slow down joe did you even check
this one
the water pressure
we're going in
let the show
seriously it's funny
you remind me of my daughter huh really
yeah that is funny
yeah she wanted to be a fireman too
so why didn't you teach her what you're
teaching me she's my daughter i love her
and i worry about her every second of my
life
if i catch the arsonist i'll have to
change the rules then i'll be the first
fireman woman the job is far too
dangerous
maybe this is a sign that it's time you
follow your own dreams
i never gave up on mine
[Music]
the mustache is very convincing it's my
dog's butt hair
[Music]
bye